Here are this week's top movies.
Hey, champ, you had a good run!
I'm sorry your racing days are coming to an end.
In Cars 3 Lightning McQueen has to prove he can keep up with a new generation of racers.
Go McQueen!
All Eyez On Me tells the story of Tupac from his early days as a rapper
to his rise as a poet and actor and a cultural icon.
Why the cameras all on me? Why on me? 'Coz I'm Tupac?
This weekend's all about us, just like old times.
Scarlett Johansson stars in Rough Night, a raunchy comedy about a bachelorette party gone horribly wrong.
He's dead!
Is everything alright?
See what's hot in theaters with this week's fanticipation.
So what's your weekend ticket going to be?
Let us know by commenting.
See you next time on weekend ticket.